they didn't ask for any of this all they
asked for sorry sorry all they asked for
was justice liz' wiping away tears as
she talks about finding hope amid the
ongoing protests against police
brutality I really do believe in the
good of people and maybe that makes me
naive the truth hurts singer has been
active on social media the past few days
speaking out after George Floyd a 46
year old black man in Minneapolis died
when a police officer pressed his knee
into his neck for more than eight
minutes
Floyd's death has sparked protests
across the nation and the world this is
the most outrageous scene as a country
and that is starting to give me the
first symbol install that I've had in a
long time I really do believe in the
good of people then maybe that makes me
naive but I've seen Minneapolis I've
seen Minneapolis rise up and do
incredible things and this isn't the
first time the Grammy winner who started
her recording career in Minneapolis
broke down in tears during an Instagram
live Sunday talking about the people of
the city who have been affected by
police brutality and the ongoing
protests they didn't ask for any of this
all they asked for
sorry-sorry
all they asked for was justice lizzo
added that the arrests of the officer
who pinned Floyd down simply isn't
enough not only do we want to see
appropriate justice indictments
convictions we want to see the entire
police organization renovated we need a
whole investigation the singer said
she's not the voice for the entire
community but she does believe in
speaking out and coming together to
fight for justice what we can do when we
actually come together for each other is
what the future of this country is all
about it definitely ain't about the past
the 32 year old musician also shared
this message of encouragement protest is
the beginning of progress not the end of
it and now that the protesters have
everyone's attention what are the next
steps that we're going to take to make
sure that we're actually moving forward
and we don't go back to this bull now is
the time the world is standing still and
waiting for action
let's make progress
[Music]